[Music]
back with my good friend guru Singh for
another edition of guru corner very
excited to talk to you today this is an
inspiration that came about because a
very close friend of ours introduced us
and we started talking and we realized
that we could talk a lot because we were
having so much of an enthusiastic
experience in discussing various things
and so I'm really honored that in all
that you do that we put together the
time to do this periodically the honor
is all mine I assure you it's a pleasure
all his this hardly mine this man is a
gift to humanity and it's a pleasure and
an honor to share your perspective on
how to live a life with higher
consciousness and today we sat down we
hashed through it we talked about what
have we talked about we talked about
depression sadness and grieving and
obviously we didn't talk the whole topic
because the topic is immense in today's
world but we did create some insight and
we created some some skillsets that
could be practiced yeah I think you guys
are gonna dig it so without further ado
please enjoy this latest edition of corn
are we ready to guess a black it is its
blackboard paint you want to write on
there we may you can you may I invite
you to express yourself yeah and is
there a and would we catch it with
camera if it's right in that general
area yeah inside this yeah kind of that
zoned yeah it looks like it's so fish it
is a visit fish yeah cool yeah yeah feel
free to editorialize yeah actually I
could mmm good because I can use the
dorsal as as a as an explanation of
something okay yeah cool were you ready
to get oh yeah
Rowland we're rolling good to see you my
friend no no clap no clap no clapping
okay no we're just in it we're in it man
great to have you out here you're
looking as stylish as ever yeah horse
and I love to see the smile on your face
so let's just open it up and how are you
doing what's going on doing very well
you know it's interesting you hear about
all that's going on you know in your
world in the world you know and then you
look down at your dog or your cat and
they're just cool yeah and so I look
down and I go oh everything must be
everything must be cool because they're
just going lunchtime dinnertime you know
it's like we're good
could we live so simply yeah well future
would probably be that simple
when we learn because we've you know I
love to make up words we've we've
complexified the world for the purpose
of selling products into it right yeah
and this is what causes a great deal of
the malaise of the current moment right
depression and grief and sadness and all
of that because people don't necessarily
get their what they consider their fair
share of the deal well we're constantly
bombarded with messages intended to
convince us that happiness lie in the
next purchase in the luxurious item in
the fancy vacation in the new car in the
in the nice watch all of these things
and and when you Intuit that from birth
and you find yourself unable to access
those items it's no mystery why it makes
people angry or upset and when they
start to believe that someone else may
be taking their ID
away then we start to become bigots we
start to have attitudes towards those
who are maybe willing to do things that
we're not willing to do and hence this
whole process that we're going through
right now with with migration you know
they call it immigration it's not
immigration it's migration it's been
happening for millions of years and it's
when when you've eaten all the grass one
location you move on to another right or
when the forest burns down in your one
location you move on to another and you
know it's interesting the idea of
nation-states because the idea of
nation-states is speaking on on this
podcast which is very you know vegan and
and plant-based territory is is a
carnivores world then territorial
protection is a carnivores world explain
that the only the only creatures on
earth that that mark their territory are
carnivores every other creature is a
grazer and welcomes others to graze with
so the the herd mentality of the of the
cloven hooves as opposed to the claw
mentality of the padded hooves has is an
interesting phenomenon and human beings
you know went through a transition
because of the Ice Ages from plant-based
plant mainly based right to carnivore
because they couldn't they couldn't find
the foods that were they were capable of
digesting so they ate the creatures that
ate the food that they couldn't digest
well I think it was an evolution from
from primarily herbivorous to a not a
hunter-gatherer culture but a gathering
hunting culture right meat was still
hard to come by plants were perhaps
easier
and then you know and so the the the
animal products were the luxury right
the results of the persistent hunt
interesting choice of words why the
luxury luxury yeah well to this day it's
still considered a luxury when you see
the rise of of the middle class in China
and in India with sections of those
cultures coming in to disposable income
for the very first time yeah there's a
sense of entitlement like okay now we
can eat these products that have been
traditionally the purview of the of the
well-to-do and then you introduce all
the fast food restaurants and meat
consumption is skyrocketing in those
populations as a result yeah and it's
all just a fantasy because the biology
tells us to do differently and you know
herbivores have a digestive tract that
is five times the height their length
and carnivores have a digestive tract
that is one-and-a-half times the height
their length and we obviously have the
longer the longest digestive tract
because it's it's that incredible
formation within the small intestine
which is they say that they'll be able
to perhaps reproduce every organ on the
body except for the small intestine
because it's so complex that that
nothing can they can't figure it out you
know and how to print it 3d print or
whatever they're going to do the idea
that we have this elongated system in
order to break down plant-based proteins
and formulate the the animal-based
proteins is is a fact that we should pay
attention to but back to the idea of
this this constant which you are saying
this constant need to access the
luxuries and the putting of the
happiness and the fulfillment on the
outs
of us is coming to a screeching halt
because as we have mined the planet and
extracted so much from underneath if you
look at the planet as a living body and
we're going down there and we're pulling
out some of the planet's deepest organ
and glandular systems processes I mean
the oil is deep in the earth really
really deep in the earth and there are
some jewelers around the world that work
with what they call ripe gold and that's
gold that is actually brought come to
the surface and usually appears in
riverbeds in the form of gold nuggets
and they say that the gold that is being
mined and leached through the chemicals
that they leach the gold ore through to
in order to come out with something that
is a value that that gold energetically
vibrationally is unfit for humans to
wear so because why is that because it's
not ripe yet
it's like eating unripe fruit if we were
to take our our entire view of what is
happening on earth and realize that
we're just the fleas that are on the
body of the earth then the same thing
that's going on within our body just
like the same thing that goes on within
the body of a flea is going on inside of
the hosts body so the planet Earth a
living creature you know fully
invigorated we're carving into it we're
sticking like we're these gigantic
mosquitoes with these long long snouts
you know sucking some of the deep fluids
out of this creature and burning them on
the surface yeah well you can kind of
understand the argument why we do that
for oil because it serves a purpose that
fuels you no necessity the necessities
of living this modern life but when you
think about things like diamonds and
gold it's preposterous I mean you
realize like how silly and infantile the
human brain is that it sees this thing
that shines a certain way and decides
that this is to be coveted this is like
continuing completely bizarre I know and
to think that that has value and that we
should be on a gold standard or a silver
standard or what have you is bizarre but
going back to your you can understand
you said you can understand why we you
know drill deeply into the earth you
know to pull out it's the same as a
mosquito the mosquito sticks that needle
deeply into your vein to suck out
something that it feels it rightfully
deserves I mean it doesn't go to your
body and say okay I'm gonna do this I
know it's illegal but I'm gonna do it no
for its life it knows that it's okay for
our life I'm just waiting for the earth
to scratch mm-hmm you know because it
back us exactly well it's starting to
it's it's rearing it's uh it's it's hand
it's getting ready for it I think at the
metaphor of its rearing its ugly head is
not an appropriate metaphor at that
point it is getting ready look what's
happening on Hawaii with the you know
with the gushing of the volcano the
hurricane that just went by some people
said they couldn't believe it there were
floods coming down the street at the
same time that there are buildings on
fire from volcano yeah it's truly
apocalyptic talk elliptic it looks like
what is that Blade Runner yeah well in
Hawaii with with it occurring right in
the midst of this like development
there's like homes all over the place
and the earth is just literally erupting
and it makes you realize that we really
are you know a tiny mosquito that we're
uh turley powerless and we take for
granted this this planet that we live on
and we believe that it's in some sort of
status quo that it's static that it will
always be the way that it is
it it only takes a little ripple like
that to remind us of how of how small we
are and I think you know whether there
was an evolutionary purpose served by it
or not we're unable to really appreciate
time in a way that allows us to proceed
with a little more humility a little
more light-footed and how we and how we
kind of traverse this this blue spinning
orb that we're all in you said you said
a phrase that is commonly used this
planet that is here to serve us and then
we reverse that phrase and say that
we're here to also serve it and in that
in that bi-directional act of service we
can live in harmony but when we're
taking more from the planet than we are
returning to the planet that's when we
start to live outside of that
orchestrated harmony that nature has
found so common this is what happens
take it from the planet take it to this
body that we have here when were when
we're pulling more out of the body when
we're depleting the body then and and
not investing into the body that's when
we get to this place of depression
because think about the word depression
depression in meteorology is when you
have a low pressure area and a high
pressure area and so depression within
our somatic being within our physical
being within our psycho emotional being
is just that we have less pressure
inside than is outside and because of
what we've just been describing thus far
it's a high pressure existence on this
planet right now and if we don't find
the ways of exuding the same kind of
impression we will be depressed so if
we're not able to impress we will become
depressed and some of this is genetic
can you learn it through your through
your cellular structure or because
genetics follows closely with the social
structure of families we learn it by
mimicking our you know our family around
us then we learn it from friends then we
learn it from all kinds of ways that we
perhaps don't have the right to impress
as much and over years and years of this
it compounds to the point of where
depression literally feels like what
happened to me in in Old Mexico where I
was you know for the sake of going
through a rite of passage I was buried
alive and the sensation of not being
able to move is a phenomenon that is
only known to those who have been buried
under earthquake rubble who have been
you know buried alive and but think of
it as a psycho emotional sensation being
deeply depressed is so common in today's
world we have soldiers coming back from
wars we have people not able to meet
their needs we have people out of work
we have homeless we have all of these
categories yeah I think I think
depression is the number one cause of
disability I may be wrong about that
but if it's not number one it's close to
it and I don't know the statistics or
the yeah it is it's debilitating people
in an unprecedented way in a way that we
have never before seen in the history of
humankind so what is contributing to
that well is that our fast-paced modern
society is it overpopulation is it the
stress and anxiety that is part and
parcel of how we live today is it is it
this Madison Avenue fueled culture that
also that always makes us feel less than
that that that compels us to measure
against measure ourselves against our
peers is it the fear that the nightly
news and stills on us that creates the
zero-sum game making us think that if
someone else gets this that they're
taking away from you
I would imagine it's all of these things
and many more that are contributing to
this state of desperation this quality
of mental illness that is moving us
further and further away from our
natural state of connection communion
and divinity think of the word that you
just used desperation desperate right
means without spirit without inspiration
without that enthusiasm and what I
believe is that all of these things are
contributing that you just mentioned but
none of them are the cause the cause is
that with this much contribution to the
state of affairs that we have the fast
pace the wallstreet that this the
consumption what have you we're not
being prepared to live in that world you
know they say that if you took a doctor
and a and an accountant and an engineer
and a schoolteacher from the 1800s and
brought them into the 21st century the
only one that would recognize their task
is the schoolteacher
and so the world through the engineers
and the medical science and everything
else that has come along to build the
modern world of the 21st century has
been going along at its pace and that
pace perhaps is accelerating but
education hasn't prepared anyone for the
new way of living education is still you
know stuck in the world of the 3 R's
which is obviously a misspelling of the
words and but the idea that kids are
dropping out of school and that there's
people with dyslexia and people with
with what they call a DD ADHD these are
not disorders these are new orders as
you can see from this art right here
this is somebody that has a new way of
looking at things and we're not
addressing those people with our
education and consequently people are
coming out into the world completely
unprepared for the world
and therefore the world has more
pressure than they do and therefore they
become depressed yeah well a couple
observations first of all I think that's
beginning to change we're seeing more
and more people deciding not to go to
college for one thing and I think it was
just last week that Google and at least
one or two other of the huge tech
companies came out and said we're no
longer requiring a college diploma for
applications for employment I mean
that's a huge change when you think
about that they're basically decoupling
that Nexus that is always existed
between higher education and upward
mobility which I think it's fastened
that is a good one isn't but you're
absolutely correct and I think that the
pace the accelerated pace with which
culture society is advancing is changing
is evolving is is is so outpacing our
evolutionary ability to adapt you know
we're still were loose in airily you
know built into our DNA into our genetic
code is a life that that looks like
whatever's going on in the you know the
indigenous tribes of Africa and you go
to those places you know you always hear
these stories oh I went to I went to
India I went to Peru I went wherever it
is and people who spend time with
cultures that are relatively immunized
from the way that we live
realise how much happier they are how
much more connected they are how much
more communal they are and and land and
content they have all of these things
that were trying so desperately to build
into our own lives but which continue to
elude us because the very things that
contribute to that which we seek we've
decided are are either optional or not
important even after having that
experience we may have that epiphany and
yet after returning to our lives we
slowly sort of return to how we're
always living and we fail to make those
those changes that would allow us to
experience life and the way these people
are one of the things that education
doesn't educate is the emotional body
you know we get some physical activity
when you said people are choosing not to
go to college I thought to myself people
are choosing not to go to football games
you know because you know the big deal
about college is now as football
stadiums that cost you know 100 million
dollars and it's all about the ranking
and football it's the ranking of
basketball it's March Madness and all of
these things you know and these higher
educational facilities have been you
know co-opted into this whole spectator
sport adventure and have not really kept
up with the times consequently people
that are really brilliant don't find any
reason for themselves to be in that
environment but going back to that sense
of not educating the emotional body
think about these depression has a value
because when you're depressed you can go
into some pretty deep places some pretty
dark places and when you go into those
places with the sense of let me explore
rather than you know let me feel
horrible those deep places can confine
character confined parts of your being
that are able to come forward there
would never be it noticed if you were
just giddy and happy all the time and
the same thing with good grief right
grieving sadness grief you know these
are also valuable moments but they're
not moments that we should use if we
want to go back to the idea of a diet we
shouldn't use them as entrees we should
use them as you know maybe spices or
maybe you know
side dishes to the main the main course
the main course you know our focus on
becoming enthusiastic becoming inspired
becoming fulfilled that's our main
course with side courses that are you
know either warning signs or augmenting
components like salt salt augments the
food so depression and grief and sadness
are all things that when they come upon
us we should go into fully but giving
ourselves the space I'm gonna take a
sick day because I'm feeling really sad
and let me go into this sadness let me
process this sadness let me gain the
messaging from this sadness just as if I
was to take a sick day because I've got
the flu yeah these emotional states are
part of what it means to be human
it was embrace and accept the fact that
it's perfectly natural and fine to
experience sadness to experience grief
to experience intermittent bouts with
depression and it's all a correction
here I don't ever do this but rich what
I'm just gonna make a correction you
said what it takes to be human I saw the
dog your dog be sad in a moment because
he couldn't come in here poor girl oh we
won't bring her in for round two but
yeah I mean where it goes back to you
know the the messages that we receive
about what's okay what's not okay in
this collective experience that we're
having and we're kind of taught like you
should love your life and be happy and
be enthusiastic all the time and if you
experienced a moment of depression that
you should actually compound that by
being ashamed we're feeling bad about
yourself because you're experiencing
something that you feel like you
shouldn't be experiencing and of course
that's it cross-purposes with with our
kind of wired right but I think there is
a difference between that sine-wave of
emotional experience that we all have
versus
is chronic states of depression and and
that's really kind of what I'm focused
on is this incredible increase in
persistent chronic states of depression
that people are experiencing and whether
that and you were saying like that you
disagreed with me about what the the
cause of that is but I want to go a
little bit I said I agree with you
they're all about they're all you that
they are the heart of the region but
that the cause was that were not
prepared mm-hmm think about chronic what
about chronic flu that you go through a
winter and you you get it you seem to be
well you go out and do something
energetically you get a relapse you get
it you go through it you seem to be well
you go out and do something
energetically you get a relapse what's
not happening what is not happening is
that there's not a full forced cure so
if I'm to go into my flu or if I'm to go
into my depression and I can fully
experience the experience as the Buddha
said anything fully experienced any of
the emotions fully experienced will
ultimately become its base factor which
is joy because going in and I've been
depressed we've all been depressed the
difference between someone who has the
awareness or the knowledge when that
depression comes on is the same as when
someone has the awareness or the
knowledge hmm you just passed the frog
when the flu comes on if you can go into
and fully work with that flu germ and
get it so that it's completely removed
from the body after you've gone through
the cycle it's the same way with
depression with sadness with other
things
with grief etc think about the grief of
people dying I've had three or four
people just recently reach out to me
because they're someone very very dear
to them has passed away and that idea of
shame that you need to grieve in private
or that you should wear dark glasses at
a funeral so to hide the tears that are
rolling down your face all of this is
exactly what you were saying that
crossed purposes that shame for sadness
shame for depression shame for grief is
something that we need to remove through
education we need to inform people that
their grief is good that their sadness
is a value and that their depression has
some message and just like the flu if
you give yourself the opportunity to go
through that cycle that you were just
mentioning then it won't become chronic
depression it will become deep
depression maybe even deeper than the
the cycles of chronic depression but it
will be fully experienced and then
relieved from the psycho emotional body
right so in other words what you're
saying is if somebody is experiencing a
depressive state that there is something
built into that like a a teachable
moment something to be learned if you
fully embrace it if you just allow
yourself to get swallowed up in it I
suppose for lack of a better word to
really feel it rather than resist it and
try to kind of surf the wave and learn
what is trying to be spoken to you
through that whatever message is trying
to be conveyed is is a trajectory out of
it right but I'm imagining somebody who
maybe is listening to this or watching
those who who is thinking I had a
chronic depression my whole life or I'm
a manic depressive or I've
I've been battling this since I was a
child constantly in pain you know I've
tried to understand I'm tried to do
everything and it's just this is how I'm
wired I need to be medicated for this
and and and feeling defensive at what
you're saying like I see not being
provocative for society who suffers and
so I would say that do not take my words
as being absolute or even that they're
my absolute perspective there are so
many contributing factors to sadness
grief depression and all of those
emotions and some of them are genetic
some of them are truly biological and
chemical to be able to take medication
is important in today's world we have
evolved to have those kinds of
substances that we can take to help
balance out chemistry's but I would say
to the audience to just take the
medication is going to resolve symptom
but it's not necessarily going to
disrupt source and so what you want to
do is you know you don't want to be
overwhelmed by the symptom so you take
you continue to take your medication but
then you also add to it something that's
going to disrupt the source code of that
what you call wiring and that is there
are so many things available I mean just
the activities that you do you know the
bike rides the swims the runs the
activities that I do the yoga the
meditation would you also do those too
and these are all things the long walks
on the beach the conversations with
loved ones that other things that we can
do to help to rewire
that that network and if the network is
is you know biological if it's inherited
from your parents if it's inherited from
through your bloodline you're going to
have to do more work but in our in our
tradition of Yogi's and mystics what we
understand is that we're a soul and body
and what you have is a body with a
particular code with a particular
formula and the body that I'm in or the
body that one of our listeners are in
viewers are in may be a body that is
prone towards sadness grief depression
their task in this life is to not only
take what they need to take so they're
not overwhelmed by it but find a pathway
to change it because anything that is
biological and that is the chemistry of
our physical body is mutable is
changeable is transformable and so I
mean you know and I know all of the
people that have been working with
diabetes and plant-based diet have found
miraculous changes people would never
believe 10 years ago 20 years ago that
diabetes could be assisted by a change
in diet yeah I mean it's a it's a it's a
shift in our perceptive perception of
agency over our lives like we never were
taught that of that word by the way
agency yeah the idea that we actually
can exert some control in how we live
our lives and what we eat how we move
how we interact with other people is a
new concept for for a lot of people who
have been taught from birth that we
should divest ourselves of that agency
invested in the hands of the
professionals so when we feel depressed
and we go to the shrink and after one
session they prescribe a medication we
say well that's the professional and
that's what we should do and I would
agree with you that
that medication has its place and its
purpose you know these are miracles of
Western culture that we've developed to
treat these conditions but I would say
that systemically our approach has gone
too far
in that we're so quick to medicate we
over medicate we medicate first and then
the real work of unpacking what is
contributing to this and how we can
confront it and ultimately overcome or
transcend it gets pushed to the side so
just like we're treating chronic health
conditions with drugs that deal with the
symptoms but not the underlying causes I
would say that we default to that same
approach with respect to mental illness
and disease in so many ways and I say
this with the caveat that I'm not
chronically depressed and I've never had
to take an s s s RI SSRI is that what
they're called a medication for any kind
of mental disorder or depression so I
can't speak from experience but just
observational II to know that so many
people I mean how many people do you
know that are on one or more of these
types of medications I mean it's endemic
that we need a new a new way of
confronting this because these the
incidence of depression is only on the
rise and as we know like these
medications seem to work or they work
with some of the symptom ology but then
they either stop working or you've got
to change the medication that you got to
take a new medication for the
side-effects of the first one and it's
add you know ad infinitum there was a
there's a guy called I'm interested in
whether you're familiar with this guy
Johann Hari who wrote a book called lost
connections I'm trying to get him on the
podcast but this is an amazing book that
really takes a a really hard deep look
at this depression problem and what is
contributing to it and what's
fascinating is that he is noticing the
same things that somebody like Dan
Buettner has noticed in the Blue Zone
cultures that live the longest and are
the happy
in other words that the people who are
most depressed are the least connected
to their elders to their extended family
to their friends because we live in this
fractured culture they lack purpose in
their lives something that the Okinawans
called a key guy you know that driving
force that gets us up out of bed in the
morning there's a lack of of you know
faith-based communities this idea that
there's something beyond the self that
is important that can be a guiding light
in our lives like all of these things we
don't move our bodies you were talking
about the cycling and the swimming like
we're we're divorced from movement all
of these habitual behaviors that define
the human race for millennia are things
that we feel like we've graduated from
and I am firmly of the opinion that that
is actually contributing to not only our
mental lack of well-being but our
physical lack of well-being as well and
and of course undermining our happiness
beautiful what I would like to say in in
communicating with your audience here
the audience here is that if you can
have this sensation of a label bipolar
manic depressed borderline all of these
dyslexic attention deficit if you can
realize that these labels and I'm using
a word that you use a lot that these
labels don't define you they describe
you that they are describing some
behavior that people have a need to
categorize and so they've given a label
to you and if you allow that label to
just be like a loose-fitting jacket that
you may not wear all day that you're
going to shed at some time continue to
take the medic
medication that is being prescribed to
you but alternately or alternatively get
involved in a program at a very small
level at a very at a very reasonable
rate bicycling walking running swimming
yoga meditation getting touch with
somebody who knows how to do it and can
show you how to do it better one of the
things that you will find over time and
I found this to be true with literally
through my life tens of thousands of
people that either wanted to give up
this or not be that or achieve this or
whatever just like you have and that is
that they realize later and a few months
all of a sudden they find that the
medication is not is is not making them
feel the way they want to feel so they
take less of it and then all of a sudden
there they feel like okay less of it was
good and then a few months later they're
still doing whatever else they're doing
in their exercise meditation reading
communicating I need less and eventually
the medication will give you up because
in very few parts of our life does the
medical prescription become a lifetime
sentence you know you have a cold you
take the medicine from the cold you're
over the cold you stop taking the
medicine you have a broken bone you get
a cast on your on your bone your bone
heals you take the cast off there are a
few things that you are to take
medicines for the rest of your life but
even those we have to question because
if we change our lifestyle if we change
our outlook all of a sudden we'll start
noticing hey you know in this moment as
I said before I look down at my dog and
the dogs just frisky and happy as ever
in a moment that seems to be going badly
on earth I realize okay even within this
moment
there is some joy that I can find I
wanted to I wanted to use your
blackboard and if the camera can catch
out go for it if the camera can catch
this and moving the microphone so it
still picks me up think of this as as
the waves on the ocean for those
listening and not on YouTube he's
drawing on our blackboard right now so
for those who are just listening going
right you can erase that in like draw a
diagram go on YouTube your PowerPoint
yeah do we have a tout can you grab like
a one of those towels there yeah just
the towel you don't need that house
solvent or whatever Thanks
so so the thing that causes the wave out
in the ocean to be this wave that is
breaking up at the beach is the fact
that the water has become shallow and
out here the water is deep and in here
the water is shallow and if we can if we
can take away the idea that shallow is a
derogatory statement and just say maybe
it's just maybe it's just a geometry
maybe it's just a way of working with
the moment when were shallow our moments
break up hmm and if they're constantly
breaking up we're going to be depressed
because we can't get a sense of
everything confusion depression sadness
grief you know all of these things just
start whirling around and we don't feel
that fulfillment so what you need to do
is you need to go deep and you're just
run out to the deep water got no water
deep water you've got to put yourself
through a pace that you do consistently
that I do consistently each in our own
ways that is causing us to go deeper
mm-hmm so for people that are listening
you drew this diagram up there of waves
with the the sort of bottom of the the
sea getting gray
and gradually less deep so in the
shallow waters where the waves are
breaking there's a lot of tumult there's
a lot of disruptions from eggs and if
you're living in that tumult and and
that's what depression is depression is
sometimes a protection from living in
that tumult and that constant you know
irregularity and confusion and let me
you just go kind of like into the num
state and you're depressed and you can
hold on to it for a long period of time
as a protective mechanism but if you did
something like you went for a good run
and you started breathing and got your
blood mony
went for a good bike ride went for a
went for a good swim went for a deep
yoga stretch went into anything that's
physical because I wouldn't think that
in this state you're gonna be jumping
into meditation and being able to gain a
lot from it but anything that you can go
into that's physical do Pilates do a
spin do aerobics do whatever and you
will find that eventually you're facing
the same situation but it's not
appearing the same and appearances are
very deceiving
what do you mean doesn't appear the same
every moment has well let me go back
into Scripture every moment has a cycle
and in the moment in this cycle you can
experience anything from the devotional
attitudes to the commotions attitudes to
the deeper depression attitudes to the
determination attitudes right the
determination attitudes are those things
like you know determination struggle
hard work effort the dark emotionals are
the fears the rages the angers the
depressions the sadness is the
commotions are the you know the chaos
the tumult confusion and all of those
and the devotions are that love joy you
know those things that are so present
around you know family and and friends
that are that are really dear to you
every moment has that cycle spinning
because you can have the same moment
with a great friend that if you're all
by yourself it's a completely different
perspective it's a completely different
observation and so we're staying in each
moment as there as the Mystics and the
Yogi's from the from the distant past
would say that in each moment it is
dependent upon how deep you're
experiencing it as to what you're going
to be able to get out of it so if we
juxtapose that back to what we were
talking and what we've been talking
about throughout if in the moment of
depression where things just don't seem
to be holding together still taking your
medication still understanding that
we're not belittling the idea this is a
reality I I am of the opinion if in
today's world you're not depressed at
times you're not paying attention you
know and so I honor the depressed and I
say if you can do something that causes
you to go deeper that same moment that
is very depressing we'll have a
different story it'll have a different
message and those are the ones that the
Buddha talked about those are the ones
that loud say talked about those are the
ones at all you know Muhammad and Jesus
talked about that are so clearly message
moments and I believe that people that
are very depressed in today's world are
people that have more connection to the
solutions than the people that are
frivolous and giddy and bouncing on the
surface right well certainly there's an
argument that they're more sensitive
because like you said if you're paying
attention and you're not experiencing
depression periodically then you know
you need to pay attention more there's
plenty to be depressed about there you
go you know and somebody who is
naturally a little more sensitive or
even more empathetic than the average
human being is probably more prone to a
depressive state than somebody who
immunizes themself from that and just
bounces along thinking everything's
hunky-dory all the time I grant you that
and it goes back to what you were saying
how humans have trained themselves over
the years you know to feel shame under
certain depths you know the depth of
depression you feel shame because you're
this the idea what has what has cured
more addicts than anything else is the
removal of the shame factor
well shame yeah shame is definitely
something that keeps addicts stuck in a
destructive cycle for sure keeps
depression to be stuck keep sadness to
be stuck keeps grief to be stuck well
the people that are honky-dory though -
I I never trust those people because I
don't think they're really anyway
they're they're wearing a mask
that's a Sanskrit perhaps that's because
honky-dory is yeah they're they're
masking something and perhaps that's a
result of shame because it's so shameful
to express your true emotional state
that it's easier to wear a mask and and
and just tell everybody that that
everything is great ooh let's dive into
that moment what you just said
there's you what julie calls them the
super duper x' because every time you
ask you see them and you ask them how
they're doing they give you a firm
handshake and with a big smile and tell
you that they're doing super duper super
duper you just said the people that are
you know riding on the surface all the
time and it's like it's always daylight
you know it's always high noon our
physical environments are creating that
now because every time we look at a
screen whether it's a screen on a
computer a screen on our phone or a
screen on an ipad we're looking at high
noon we're looking at the light of high
noon this this is heavy blue light
that's coming off the screen and what
it's giving us is this sensation that
you got to always be up you got to
always be on top of it's SuperDuper what
you say
SuperDuper hunky-dory yeah you got a
better honky I think SuperDuper is
probably better than honky honky door is
like pretty good SuperDuper
that implies that lighting also I think
hunky-dory
Yeah right for sensor yeah
and you can't always be up how you doing
I'm doing all right every once in a
while take off the mask and just say
don't feel sorry for me but I'm feeling
horrible you know one of the things that
we have to watch out for is when we
develop a an acute pattern a consistent
pattern of not feeling well we are
actually if we're around people probably
being fed by some sympathy and sympathy
is a bit like a candy bar because it can
give you a boost
a boost of energy in the moment but it's
not sustaining energy well I can create
a narrative that people and the
dependency come dependent upon yeah and
so you should check your sympathy factor
if you are in fairly consistent sadness
depression grief etc you should check to
see if if you've gotten so accustomed to
sympathy that you're rejecting it but
knowing that it's always there to be
accepted also these are things that need
to be viewed within the individual life
but the fact is is that diving into that
that depression diving into that sadness
and taking off the mask and admitting it
and saying you know I'm not looking for
anything from you but I just got to say
you know what's happening in the world
today or what's happening in my world
today or what just happened you know in
my home or what whatever you know you
know I'm not feeling good or you could
even say if it's chronic you know what I
haven't felt good for 10 years and then
all of a sudden the cocktail party goes
silent to heck with the cocktail party
yeah you know let's be honest this is
the thing I mean I think it's terrifying
for a pee
well if I admit that I'm not feeling
good you know what are people gonna
think of me and I think that goes right
back into this discussion around shame
and around vulnerability you know we're
taught to good our self in a certain way
to navigate social circles in a manner
that will allow us to maintain that that
trajectory of upward mobility and to act
in contravention of that is to put it
risk everything that you've staked your
life upon which provokes fear and that
sense of shame is the ultimate
prophylactic against behaving in a way
that actually would contribute to
greater health I have a couple like
little mantras around this the first is
shame can't survive the light I didn't
make that I didn't come up with that
myself I'm sure something somebody else
said that but I love that lock roach
it's it's it's it's uh you know for
Shiff we're ashamed about something the
most terrifying thing would be to shed
light on it to expose that in a
vulnerable way to another human being
the state can be very high for people
but ultimately placing that into into
you know a social setting in which it
can be discussed in a mature way is the
path to healing mm-hmm but it requires
us to be vulnerable and we're not raised
to be vulnerable that contravenes you
know what we've been led to believe
makes us a man makes us masculine but I
think that vulnerability that
willingness to be vulnerable is the
ultimate courage and when you can expose
that which you're ashamed of from a
place of wanting to heal it asking for
help allowing yourself to be vulnerable
requires a tremendous amount of courage
but is it's very difficult for most
people for myself for anybody courage is
a word that's made up of two words core
and edge and core means heart it's a
Latin
word meaning heart and ash means time
and courage means a time of the heart
and so getting people to be willing will
willingness is also a mechanism of the
heart getting people to be willing and
courageous is something and I always
look at it the same way as that drawing
and that is that our trajectory can't be
let's fix it right now our trajectory
has to be something more like let's fix
it this year let's give ourselves twelve
months let's give ourselves 18 months
let's give ourselves enough time so that
we're not looking for immediate
gratification and if we get setbacks we
don't notice them as much as if the
setback means that we didn't succeed in
this day and so I look at these things
like overcoming depression and when it
comes on you go dive into it and live in
it until it's completed its storytelling
and then you come out of it these are
the kinds of things that we can work
with I would say to the to the audience
that's listening or viewing that you
know we've got two people here talking
with each other and you know we're
sharing ideas of things that we have
learned throughout our years of life and
things that we have studied throughout
our our efforts but every single moment
is a teacher and vulnerability the word
that you used a moment ago is something
that men aren't taught to be and one of
the things that is taking place in the
masculine world is this real dominance
of the bravado and the subordination of
vulnerability and so men that are
listening to this podcast as well as
women have to find groups that are
safe arenas in which they can expose the
things that are true you know 12-step
programs are famous for that men's
groups women's groups are famous for
that find reach out there and find some
way I just came back from we have a
men's camp in Canada every August and I
just came back from teaching at that we
live together for a week at a like at a
Boy Scout camp and you know we all eat
together it's vegan it's you know it's
very it's very high-energy but people
come into that with a lot of baggage
that they don't leave with because in
those circles that are completely safe
which you can find you know throughout
the world you can find those kinds of
circles that you can relate you can take
off your mask you can become vulnerable
in that moment you can start practicing
you don't necessarily have to take it
out on the big stage of your life and
suddenly be vulnerable in the midst of
everybody that you've been completely
shielded from for a long time but coming
out in vulnerability and safe settings
learning what are the muscles what is
what's the coordination that it takes to
be vulnerable in a moment and then you
can also practice it when you're on your
own or with when you're with those close
intimate relationships of yours and
start being more vulnerable start
allowing people in when you're feeling
sadness when you're feeling grief when
you're feeling depression so that you
can have assistance in the exploration
that's that's how you heal that's how
you overcome all of these all of the
back you know the bag is that we carry
around I mean in addition to not being
taught the value of vulnerability as men
we're also taught to be self-sufficient
in other words asking for help is a
weakness that's a vulnerability that's
unacceptable and I can tell you that
when I was struggling with alcohol and
just could not stop drinking I was
adamant that I on my own would be able
to find a solution to this problem and I
absolutely refused to ask for help
because I believed that I could handle
it
that the manly way forward was just to
handle your [ __ ] man like sorta to how
it you don't need to dump it on somebody
else and make it their problem
that's weakness strength is cleaning
house on your own and as long as I
proceeded with that mentality that hole
that I was digging just got deeper and
deeper and deeper until the pain was so
great that everybody who was saying
would you please ask for help will you
please ask for help
I finally had no other choice but to do
just that and I can tell you that was
incredibly painful because it cut across
everything that I thought made me who I
was which was this self-sufficient
person I had imagined that every success
that I had had in my life was a result
of my ability to buckle down and work
hard and get it done and I could not
understand why that mentality couldn't
solve this problem but ultimately I sit
here across from you today because I
like to say it was because of courage
but it wasn't it was because I was so
broken and I had no other Avenue of
recourse but it was that act of asking
for help of surrender of raising my
hands and saying I can't do this anymore
I don't know how to solve this problem
can you please help me it's a vulnerable
act and it took a lot of courage to do
that and it was terrifying and I felt
very ashamed all of the emotions that
were discussing here today but that was
the first step in addressing this
problem that ultimately was going to
kill me and in that experience I was
able to find a way to get sober to stay
sober and that's why I feel so strongly
about this that we need to re-imagine
what it means to be a man what it means
to be strong and and really embrace the
fact that that vulnerability is courage
that asking for help is not a weakness
and I say that because millions and
millions of not just men but people are
suffering tremendously all over the
world
they're stuck in situations that could
be redressed people who are harboring
conditions that could be healed but
they're not a lot they're not availing
themselves of the solution because
they're afraid to ask for help because
that feels like weakness and another
thing that comes out of that distortion
of not being able to have a balanced
world not being able to be vulnerable
not being able to look weak because
you're asking for help mm-hmm is a
strong contributor to the dilemma that
we have today in the world which is that
men are predators their sexual predators
their power predators they take
advantage of other people whether
they're sexually oriented or or
territorially oriented the world is a
predatory place and this is not going to
bring about inner peace or world peace
or any kind of peace it's not going to
bring about anything I loved hearing
what you were saying is that you know it
came it came out of being broken but
what came out of being broken was that
there was no alternative but to be
courageous but to be vulnerable and if
we could get the listeners and the
viewers to understand as we're talking
about sadness and grief and depression
that you know these two are addictive
behaviors these two are familiarities
you know a lot of the things that we're
dealing with in in this cycle of
behavior is that we move towards the
familiar so that if you have been
chronically depressed if you have been
chronically sad or grieving it's a
familiarity and just like you were
saying you felt that if what was
familiar to you and I loved what you
were saying what was familiar to you was
it I have to be strong and I have to do
this by myself otherwise my whole image
shatter
and I can't live in a shattered image
these people that are listening and
viewing this show have to understand
that that it's okay to let the image
shatter but to do it in a safe location
don't just do it you know out there in
the public view because the public isn't
ready to view it the public isn't ready
to respond to it and it may only
compound your shame it may only compound
your sense of inadequacy so we would be
we would be fortunate to recommend that
just like what you've been through and I
really respect your journey that that
the people that are listening that may
be in a chronic state of depression that
these are not unlike alcoholism they're
not unlike you know drug addiction it's
a habit it's a pattern it has an
emotional component it has a mental
component it has a physical component
people get very accustomed to being who
they are and if it's only medicine that
is going to help them one has to
understand that medicines main effort is
to and it's in its a compassionate
effort it's now I'm not I'm not
ridiculing it in any way it's main
effort is to remove the symptom because
the symptom is so painful mm-hmm but if
the core problem is your identity you
have a larger mountain to climb or may
become so habituated to our sense of who
we are to our identities and if you are
suffering whether it's alcoholism or
from some other kind of you know mental
or emotional disease and I say that like
dis-ease a sense of a lack of ease in
your life then I would challenge you to
call into question that sense of self
that you're clinging to so strongly
beautiful how's that working out for you
and and the fear that you have around
letting go of that actually is the key
that can unlock the door to rebuilding a
new identity that will serve you in a
much healthier way and and and I respect
the fact that that's terrifying because
I like to be in that place but to
understand that consciousness is larger
than this this narrative that you've
sewn around who you are and that we all
have the ability to grow and transcend
whatever whatever is currently holding
us back
hmm that is complete I think we did our
first hour of Guru cornerman how do you
feel I feel great is it good it's great
all right man let's take a break and
come back for round two all right all
right my that was such a great summary
of the whole thing now I want you to
read this painting just say peace
implants yes
peace and plans
[Music]
you